as one day as a lion and I'm glad I love
this because then it would be it's what
would you say if you didn't though well
I wouldn't maybe I just wouldn't bring
it up really I don't know if I'd bring
it well I would probably say hey got a
new movie coming out tell us about that
yeah but what I liked about this and you
kind of downplayed it you were like you
know because you that's who you are you
don't let go you know you're like you
know it's good it's great cash it's
really a good movie and I'm like all
right because you're not like me like oh
man you got to see this and you and I
started watching it immediately I was
like oh my God you knew exactly what
this was
it shot so well in the first 10 minutes
so much [__] goes down where I love that
you're like this hit man but you're kind
of you have the you have a heart right
you have like the anti-hand you should
not be a hit man but you are and you're
like oh [__] right you see JK Simmons
character
um you play Jackie yeah and you see him
you're supposed to take him out you got
this guy who's opening scene with the
guys lying on the couch the guy who's
your boss and he's he just farts and he
rolls over against you come on you're
gonna do this I didn't write the fart
that was I love farts okay and it's only
one fart it's like a fart movie guys
it's it's it's a very fun intense kind
of surprising and I'm watching this and
you and you call me like look he's he's
a cowboy he got off his horse or
something right I can't I can't kill
this guy he's like [__] kill him
right what are you doing and he put this
mustache on and you go into this place
into this Diner and
whatever I thought was going to happen
it didn't turn out that way okay and I
love the surprise of it all and I I love
the connections and what I love is also
that it's grounded in this goofy way
like a Tarantino movie yeah or like a
comb Brothers yeah those are my favorite
kind of movies man when you take really
like horrible situations and find comedy
in them and humor I think it's the
hardest thing to do when you succeed at
it I think it's you know what it works
for me is watching you like not ham it
up you're very subtle right even though
you're doing some crazy [__] right uh
and you're a little neurotic yeah yeah
and watching JK Simmons completely
commit to this [__] badass and when
he's speaking you're like
this is for Real yeah because it could
easily be oh we're having we're doing a
fun movie when everybody thinks they're
doing this kind of movie it never works
no I agree and that's why I think it
works and it's got like Frank Grillo and
JK Simmons and Tara Manning and Virginia
Madsen I always remember her from
Candyman I love trying candy man because
you know the horror movies all around
yeah uh George Carroll it's like
and you produced it you're an executive
producer on this I wrote it and I I you
know produced it but yeah there was a
guy wrote it I wrote it yeah
there's a guy named Jeremy Rosen who
produced it he really should get the
credit for producing it I I just did the
like yeah I want a producer credit and I
helped cast it a little bit but he was a
producer did you call all the actors uh
not all but JK you called you you know
JK I do we did a movie 15 years ago and
uh I've everything I ever write I'm
thinking of him for something and he's
such a he's such a no [__]
non-hollywood guy that like you know he
reads something if he likes it he'll
tell you if he doesn't like it he
doesn't have some agent telling him what
he should or should not do he you know
he if he likes something he does it and
so you called him said look I got the
script I think it's great I said read it
he said I like it if the agents can
figure out how to pay me what I need to
get paid I'll do it and so he won't you
know you got to pay a guy yeah of course
you know I remember I did a movie called
pool hall junkies which didn't I
remember but it was a fun little movie
and they got Chris walking yeah and you
know he got paid a lot he was most of
the budget yeah he only worked like four
days yeah that's right how do we get
that I want to get that Jesus you just
gotta you gotta do something you have to
have a voice like he he's kind of become
a parody of himself yeah who doesn't
have a question everybody does walk and
I've been doing it since the 90s and no
one cares anymore me too I remember when
you used to do it when people got
impressed oh my God yeah but I always
feel like I do it like one I'm one of
the best I think I'm one of the best do
you we're not gonna do it here no I
could do it I can do it too you you're
welcome fine here we are it's 1990 all
over again all over again yeah